I think all of the chemistry and all of
the science is in service of trying to
create aesthetic beauty in a glass when
you sip a glass of well aged smoky
whiskey
you could almost taste the years that's
been sitting in a barrel and that's what
allows distillers to charge in the
thousands of dollars for a top-shelf
bottle so the boost sits in a barrel for
decades and decades and decades the wood
sort of slowly dissolves into it and as
the polymer structures that make the
wood would slowly fall apart they shed
all of these precursor chemicals that
turn into different stuff that tastes
really good is one a hop aboard careful
getting on it is on water
we took this boat ride deep into this
jungle to talk with Brian Davis one of
the cofounders of lost spirits
distillery he's part of a community of
craft distillers who have opened up shop
in the last 10 years riding a wave of
interest in premium beverages so that's
actually a little bit top secret ish in
terms of exactly what it's doing but
it's part of a set of experiments that
are designed around scaling up the
technology that we've been working on
you'll find a lot of oddities inside of
Davis's distillery everything from a
hypnotic floating carousel to godlike
statues to a dragon skull sitting in a
room straight out of the island of dr.
Moreau but you won't find rows of oak
barrels aging booze
that's because he's developed an
untraditional way of making spirits
taste like they've been sitting around
for decades when in fact they're a mere
6 days old I got to be the first guy to
recreate effectively the chemical
signature of 15 to 20 year old bottles
of booze in a laboratory Davis who's won
multiple awards for his product invented
a reactor that mimics the natural aging
process when booze is left in a barrel
is that sort of a thing that put us on
the map and created the lab in the in
the business model this time and money
saving technology could transform the
market for aged spirits by bringing
these products within reach of a larger
community of liquor consumers
Davis took an unconventional path to
becoming a liquor distiller he started
making his own booze in high school when
he couldn't get a good enough fake ID
built sort of a rudimentary still out of
crap from the garage and and made some
pretty awful booze he eventually went to
art school for college where he studied
sculpture and then went on to design for
amusement parks that jungle you saw
earlier sits in a warehouse in downtown
Los Angeles and it's one of the many
worlds that Davis says he's trying to
recreate for drinkers through their
taste buds I certainly still think like
an artist and it definitely influences
the approach that I take to what I'm
trying to make I think all of the
chemistry and all of the science is in
service of trying to create aesthetic
beauty in a glass the liquor world has
been forbidding to small distillers
since the repeal of prohibition to get
started in the industry Davis had to get
creative when he arrived in California
with his significant other Joanne hiruta
who's also his business partner they
tried to get into the whiskey and rum
business but Davis says he needed almost
a half a million dollars in backing to
produce a three year old bottle we were
utterly broke so he started down the
path of figuring out how to you know go
get old boilers out of apartment
buildings in San Francisco on Craigslist
for five hundred bucks and you know we
built all the stills out of sheet copper
or the hammer and torch but they still
needed warehouses and barrels we just be
literally sitting there going ok we'll
we'll sell our first bottle of booze
when I'm 60 and I thought well I mean
it's only chemistry right you know I
don't I don't really know anything about
chemistry but how hard can it be so
Davis went on the internet and started
watching YouTube videos of chemistry
classes taught at MIT and then every
time I had a vocabulary word I didn't
understand yeah just pause it and then
go to Wikipedia and put in the
vocabulary word and then read that and
then it would typically reference other
vocabulary words that I didn't
understand you can just sort of tunnel
your way down the rabbit hole until all
of a sudden one day read a paper and go
wow I understood all everything that
said you know
[Music]
by 2013 Davis had figured out how to
force the chemical reaction called ass
tariff occation which is the main
driving force behind barrel aging you're
not like cooking with wood it's not like
you're flavoring spirits with a barrel
you're actually triggering a series of
downstream chemical reactions that
change the nature of the product but he
couldn't come up with a natural way to
mimic the effects of time and break down
the polymer structures in a wooden
barrel that give a well aged bottle of
booze its taste
one day while thinking about how he had
to replace the Sun damaged wooden deck
attached to his mobile home he had an
epiphany so I'm sitting there standing
on this old worn-out deck and the little
voice in the back of my head is saying
you need to put a new coat of paint on
the deck but it sort of set it in
science and nerds terms right which was
you know gee the sunlights doing one
hell of a number on the polymers that
are holding the structural integrity of
the wood together on your deck you
should really put a new coat of paint on
it and I sort of got like maybe a
hundred feet away and then I liked his
idea was that by blasting wood with
light he could speed up the effects of
degrading a barrels wood into alcohol so
he went to Home Depot and bought every
lighting fixture and bulb he could get
his hands on and I called my electrician
had him come over and we unplugged all
of the power from everything on the
property and routed all the electricity
into the barn and then set up all of
these different light fixtures aimed at
different jars of booze with the wood in
them and then turned them all on running
a whole different giant battery of tests
[Music]
he also found that the type of wood used
in his process impacts the taste one of
his current projects is to recreate rum
from the 1860s and 70s aged in American
chestnut barrels the problem is that the
American chestnut tree went extinct in
1915 so we went to auction and started
buying furniture made out of American
chestnut and then bring it back and
slapping it on a table saw and you know
buzzing off pieces of it so you could
extract the good usable wood and then
testing and charring it and using it to
try to create the profiles that we would
have gotten from barrels today you can
find Davis's products and specialty
liquor stores and he regularly appears
at distilling conferences the technology
has talked about endlessly on liquor
blogs too
liquor companies have lobbied for laws
that outline strict definitions of what
you may call certain types of alcohol so
he's had to come up with some
non-traditional names like for example
we make what for all intents and
purposes is a very highly awarded scotch
whiskey that we call abomination and we
label it as a heavily peated malt and
have no idea what that means
but Davis doesn't mind the variety he
dreams of a future in which liquor store
shelves are lined with bottles that
customers don't recognize as a consumer
none of it would make any sense and
you'd have to look it up and actually
understand what you're buying if you
look at this from an art world's point
of view once upon a time sculptures were
made of stone or bronze paintings were
done in oil there were two styles of
painting that you could do in the case
of distilled spirits we sort of
gradually evolved into that same
position but the industry had the
advantage of being able to consolidate
after prohibition so instead of having
10,000 small distilleries across the
United States you suddenly had like 10
right and so all that consolidation that
these guys made basically the same thing
and then ultimately they wanted to try
to legally enshrine their own monopolies
in and so they created laws that said
you know whiskey must be exactly this I
sort of view myself as that same
antagonist to those Canon istic systems
and have a ball trying to see how many
monkey wrenches I can throw the
arguments in the systems without
breaking the laws
[Music]